Speaker 1: Well, it's happening again as we
continue to wait and see whether there will
even be an attempt made to hold Donald Trump
accountable for his various actions while
president related to the Jan. six Trump riots.
Donald Trump appeared Sunday night on Mark
Levin's Fox News show, and he admitted to the
crime of obstruction, and it is not the first
time that he has done it, Trump straight up told
Mark Levin. I fired James Comey. If I didn't, he
would have taken down the president. He would have
taken down me. This is an admission that Trump's
firing of Comey was deliberately calculated
to stop the progress of an investigation
of which Trump was a subject and which
Trump calculated would ultimately come back
to hurt him. This is obstruction of justice.
Let's take a look at this first clip. The content
is also part of a broader situation of hilarity
and horror, which is that Donald Trump was on Mark
Levin's show to promote his picture book. And you
might be saying, What do you mean? A picture book?
Yeah. We covered a week or two ago. Like many
past presidents, Donald Trump has put out a book.
Unlike past presidents, Donald Trump's book
is a picture book with captions that read like
tweets. Many of them are insults about people like
Nancy Pelosi and others. I mean, at every layer,
at every level, it's completely pathetic and
humiliating, but Donald Trump is promoting it
anyway. So let's get right into the moment in
question here. I would say listen carefully,
but you barely need to listen carefully to
understand what it is Donald Trump is saying here.
Speaker 6: The most incredible things. Don't
forget I fired Comey. Had I not fired Comey.
You might not be talking to me right now about a
beautiful book of four years at the White House.
And we'll see about the future. The
future's going to be very interesting.
But I fired Comey that whole group. And now that
group is coming back again. I mean, it's not
believable. It shouldn't be allowed to happen.
Speaker 1: Shouldn't be allowed to have
I fired Comey and if I hadn't, you might not be
talking to me right now. So you knew that Comey
continuing to investigate might be bad for you,
and you fired him to interfere and obstruct with
the investigation, interfere with and obstruct
the investigation. That's obstruction of justice.
Trump says I couldn't have survived if I did
not fire James Comey and in this next clip.
And now it's this is a former president,
guys. Trump even raises the term deep state
that it was deep state actors. Off the
wall, bonkers stuff from anyone. Never
mind a former president of the United States.
Speaker 6: The words deep state, but they've been
there for a long time. They've been in the Justice
Department, they've been in the FBI, they've been
in CIA. So you're coming into a hornet's nest. I
was going to say before, if I didn't fire Comey,
they were looking to take down the president
of the United States if I didn't fire him.
And some people said he made a mistake when he
fired Comey. And now those same people said it
was the most incredible, instinctual moves
that they've ever seen. Because I wouldn't
I might be here with you. Perhaps we'll be talking
about something else, but I don't think I could
have survived if I didn't fire him because it
was like a hornet's nest. When I fired him,
they all went crazy against each other.
Speaker 1: So multiple admissions to obstruction.
You know, we could focus in on the deep state
stuff. The deep state stuff is not dissimilar from
the sort of shadow government conspiracies we've
talked about before. These take many different
forms. Sometimes the the just not sometimes. The
gist of shadow government conspiracy theories
is that the real elected officials are merely a
facade. There is an underbelly of those who really
control what's going on, and it's sort of a fill
in the blank. Choose your own adventure of who
that is. Sometimes it's the Illuminati. Sometimes
it's Democrats. Sometimes it's a pedophile ring.
The juice is a classic. It could be, you
know, the Saudis. I mean, every version
of shadow government exists. Deep state is just
a version of that. That's all it is in Trump's
promoting it. So we're not even going to get into
that obstruction of justice. Donald Trump says in
no uncertain terms here. I fired James Comey
because the FBI was looking into my actions,
and it might have been really bad if he were
able to complete that investigation unfettered.
So I stopped it. Think about any other
scenario in which an individual takes
actions to prevent law enforcement from
investigating them. It's obstruction,
it's obstruction. And you all know that I've
said some of you yell at me when I say it.
I don't think Trump will ever do a day in prison.
I just don't see it. And I still think that that's
the case. I don't think Trump's going to do a day
in prison. But without a doubt, the admissions
that he has now made multiple times the facts
it points to. Attorney General Merrick Garland
should be pushing forward on a Trump probe here.
We don't know exactly what Garland is up to. It
doesn't really seem like he's doing it. How many
times does Donald Trump have to implicate himself
before someone will say, OK, you know what? Let's
do it. Let's look into it. Statute of limitations.
Not the reason. Five years on obstruction, we
are at four and a half. We are starting to get
tight on time when it comes to the statute
of limitations on obstruction, as far as I
understand. But it is not yet up. Is it as simple
as there's one set of rules for people like Trump
and a different set of rules for normal people?
Maybe now we're getting warmer. Is there something
here about putting partizanship aside? Even
a democratic attorney general understands
that opening up the door to the prosecution of a
former president is a door that he doesn't want
to open and maybe has been encouraged not to open.
Maybe, I don't know. But at this point, how many
times is Trump going to admit what he did before
it's taken seriously and actually investigated?